titanfall 2 is a game about momentum it
knows when to rush forward at a
breakneck pace it knows when to give us
time to breathe both in its
single-player campaign and its
multiplayer modes titanfall 2 is a more
measured pace than its predecessor
making the build-up to its climactic
battles just as enticing as the events
themselves it's every bit as kinetic and
fluid is the first titanfall but in many
respects it's a much better shooter as
with the first game from respawn
entertainment titanfall 2 revolves
around two layers of combat conventional
firefights between human combatants and
clashes between massive bipedal mechs as
a boots on the ground pilot titanfall 2
feels more like a traditional shooter
albeit one with pristine controls in a
fluid traversal system then it comes
time to call in your mechanical ally
from orbit and everything changes
because it's when these two layers
engage in a tug of war that titanfall 2
reveals its true brilliance what was
once an even fight becomes a David
versus Goliath scenario as a pilot
escapes the cover and calls in a Titan
of her own momentum often shifts like
this as one team gains control of the
battlefield only to lose ground when the
other notice is a weak spot
this is crucial in titanfall 2 now more
than ever
combat requires forethought and
intelligence despite the bombast and
spectacle titanfall 2 is a thinking
person shooter the sequels new Titans
embody the sentiment in place of the
basic light medium and heavy variants
from the first game titanfall 2 employs
six distinct walking battle tanks with
Arsenal's of their own they're almost
like superheroes one attacks with a
thermite launcher in flame weapons while
the other fires a chest mounted laser
cannon an unlucky opponents each of
these titans abilities are easy to learn
but difficult to master as the saying
goes their loadout to immediately make
sense but the more you play the more
emergent scenarios you'll find learning
the intricacies of each Titan is
paramount not just for offense but
defense to their elements of fighting
games or MOBAs here each Titan has a
tell and you only have a few brief
moments to counter it to your advantage
the new Titans also lend a very
different pace to multiplayer matches
while the first titanfall was always
cranked up to 11 so to speak with
smaller maps and cook
cutter tighten variants focused on
dealing damage titanfall 2 understands
the value of breathing room it doesn't
burn you out with an onslaught of
firefights its match you're focused on
exterior environments and are often on
the larger wider side giving you time to
plan out your attack based on your Titan
load outs each multiplayer mode
facilitates titanfall to interwove and
combat systems but also twist the
formula in creative ways bounty hunt is
my favorite you gain currency by killing
the enemy team and AI grunts that litter
the map and at the end of each wave
you're given the chance to deposit your
loot in banks the thing is the other
team is doing the same thing it's a
frantic game of cat and mouse that
increases in tension as the banks open
and players rush to gain points that
expert attention to pacing in momentum
carries over into titanfall 2
single-player mode as well
it follows Jack Cooper a militia
rifleman turned pilot and his sentient
Titan BT 72 74 as they battle the
interstellar manufacturing corporation
and the apex predator mercenary group
unfortunately the writing here is
lacking your main enemies are outlandish
villains and the plot ends abruptly
before it feels like it should and while
there is often humour and sentiment to
be found between Cooper and BT the jokes
become wrote when they focus too much on
the Titans inability to understand human
sayings and turns of phrase missing me
already
I was not shooting at you that would be
a violation of protocol three yeah never
mind yet in terms of design and pacing
the for our campaign is fantastic it
gradually increases in velocity and
scope coalescing in midair ship battles
frantic Titan charges and old-school
boss fights well now we're talking as
you progress through these missions
you'll unlock all of titanfall to's
Titan loadouts getting the ability to
swap between them on the fly this grants
the campaign a dynamism not entirely
present in multiplayer you can enter a
battlefield discern this situation and
choose a different Titan based on this
scenario all in the span of several
seconds
good work pilot your skills are greatly
improving titanfall 2 accomplishes
several things it introduces seemingly
minor changes to its multiplayer sphere
but results in more fluid pacing in a
more intelligent gameplay loop it adds a
single-player campaign that builds in
momentum with each mission culminating
in grandiose battles that make use of
both Titan and pilot combat and lastly
titanfall 2 demonstrates a vitality that
its predecessor couldn't wear as the
first titanfall kept up its breakneck
pace throughout the entirety of every
match titanfall 2 understands that
sometimes dialing things back for a few
moments can make the long run much more
enjoyable in many ways titanfall 2 feels
like the game respawn should have made
in 2013 it's a fantastic sequel it's a
fluid shooter it's a spectacular game
range 95 meters projectile mass 89
kilograms
trust me
you
[Music]